أعتقد السيد.  الرئيس يتحدىك
بشأن أحد التصريحات التي أدليت بها
في نهاية الحملة
الانتخابية في منتصف المدة هناك نحن نسير على ما يرام إذا كنت
تعرف السيد.  الرئيس أن هذه القافلة
كانت غزوًا كما تعلمون أعتقد
أنها ليست السيد.  الرئيس كارافان لم
يكن غزوًا ، إنه مجموعة من
المهاجرين الذين ينتقلون من أمريكا الوسطى
نحو الحدود مع الولايات المتحدة ، شكرًا
لك على تان لماذا
وصفتها على هذا النحو كما
اعتبرتها غزوة ولدي اختلاف
في  رأي هل تعتقد أنك
شيطنت المهاجرين المعروفين باسم Electro
الآن لمحاولة أريدهم أن يأتوا
إلى البلد ولكن يجب أن يأتوا
من الناحية القانونية ، فأنت تعلم أنه يجب عليهم القدوم من
خلال عملية أريدها أن تكون
عملية و  أريد أن يأتي الناس
ونحتاج إلى الأشخاص في حملتك ،
انتظر ، أنت تعرف سبب حاجتنا إلى الورقة
لأن لدينا مئات الشركات
تتحرك في مكاننا ، نحتاج إلى الأشخاص الذين تحتوي
حملتك على إعلان يظهر مهاجرين
يتسلقون فوق الجدران ويعرضونه من أجله
ولكن  لم يكونوا
ممثلين ولن يفعلوا ذلك ، لم يكونوا ممثلين جيدًا ، لا
هذا فقط هل تعتقد أنهم ممثلون
لم يكونوا ممثلين لم يأتوا
من هوليوود ، هؤلاء كانوا
أشخاصًا هذا كان بالفعل كما تعلم  لقد
حدث ذلك قبل بضعة أيام وهناك
مئات الأميال على الرغم من أنها تبعد
مئات ومئات الأميال ،
هذا ليس ابتكارًا بصراحة
أعتقد أنه يجب عليك السماح لي بتشغيل البلد
الذي تدير فيه CNN وإذا قمت بذلك جيدًا ،
فدعني تقييماتك  أسألك هل أنت قلق
هذا يكفي الأشخاص الآخرين الذين قالوا
الآن يؤذيني سيدتي السيد.  رئيس هذا
يكفي هذا الرئيس ، أود
أن أسأل عن أحد هؤلاء في التحقيق في روسيا
، هل أنت قلق من أنك ربما لم
تكن قلقًا بشأن أي شيء يتعلق
بتحقيقك لأنه خدعة ،
هل هذا يكفي لإخماد السيد الميكروفون.
السيد الرئيس ، هل أنت قلق بشأن
لوائح الاتهام الواردة في هذا
التحقيق
السيد.  الرئيس ، سأخبرك بما
يجب أن تخجله CNN من نفسها بعد أن كنت
تعمل معهم ، فأنت شخص فظيع وقح
لا يجب أن تعمل لصالح CNN
، وأعتقد أنك لست
شخصًا وقحًا جدًا كما تعامل سارة هوكابي
أمر فظيع والطريقة التي تعامل بها
أشخاصًا آخرين فظيعة ، لا يجب أن تعامل
الناس بهذه الطريقة ، المضي قدمًا.
لك
أيضًا حتى أفهم أن أكون صادقًا ، لذا
دعني أطرح عليك سؤالًا إذا كان بإمكاني
مرارًا وتكرارًا ، فأنت أفضل
السيد.  الرئيس ، مرارًا وتكرارًا على
مدار الموضوع ، اجلس من فضلك
جيدًا عندما تبلغ عن أخبار كاذبة ،
لا عندما تبلغ عن أخبار كاذبة تفعلها شبكة CNN
كثيرًا ، فأنت
عدو للشعب.  الرئيس على مدار
الدورة